this is from the daily wire
the climate may be getting hot but aoc's
new movie is most definitely not well
done representative Alexandra Casa
Cortez has a new documentary out to the
end
um and if movie theaters are paying
attention to ticket sales they realize
it's already run to the end the flick
opened on December 9th at 120 theaters
but since then it's made
9667 okay you know it's about a week
on over 100 screens it's made less than
ten thousand dollars that is 80 bucks a
screen
and let's say the tickets are 16 25 as
they are at Regal theaters that would
equate to fewer than 600 people who
actually saw it so that's about uh do
the math on that so that's like um
just about five people five or six
people a theater went to go see this
movie
perhaps viewers just didn't want to sit
through this this is uh the movie
synopsis stopping the climate crisis is
a question of political courage and the
clock is ticking over three years of
turbulence and crisis four young women
fight for a green New Deal and ignite a
historic shift in U.S climate politics
now the film Drew 83 approval from
Rotten Tomatoes of course but
nobody actually wants to see this thing
and I know that you're really hoping
that you'll get a chance to watch the
trailer of this because you're hearing
the description you're thinking I need
to see some clips of this thing and
don't worry I got you covered uh here's
the trailer
fighting for change politically requires
faith
we are building an army of young people
to stop the climate crisis and create
millions of good jobs for Our Generation
everyone wants to talk about this
dispassionately but this is a world that
I'll raise my kids in
the more Centrist Wing is arguing that
they want to maintain the status quo
ain't nobody gonna keep us down this is
going to be the moonshot of Our
Generation moments of Crisis crack open
the window of possibility
sometimes I feel like my job is to get
my hands dirty you're not going to trick
us hell no
now is the time to leverage our power we
have tens of thousands of new people
joining
we're in the battle for the soul of the
democratic party make them feel like
they're going to lose their seats if
they don't support this let's stop
listen stop watching it so you've seen
of it
um
a few things first
it it interesting things going on here I
mean nothing interesting in the film
itself but um first the Democrat Party
just doesn't have any stars at all they
don't they don't have any interesting
people
in the Democrat Party
um AOC is the closest
and yet you know she's she's probably
the biggest star
in the Democrat Party she's not the one
that has the most influence in
Washington
for sure but but she's the biggest star
uh most well-known most famous popular I
guess
and yet and yet still like she's the
best they can do as far as that goes and
and yet nobody cares because she's
actually not interesting at all
it's not an interesting person
part of the problem is that in order to
be interesting you have to have some
rough edges you know you need to have
some aspects of yourself that aren't
politically correct
that's what makes someone interesting
um but when you perfectly fit yourself
into this politically correct box it may
prevent you from getting backlash it may
make you above criticism in the
mainstream fine but just like it's not
interesting
and also the left once again as we see
they find it difficult to make films
that preach their message in an
appealing and entertaining way they
didn't always have this difficulty
because the left has been the Hollywood
has been left leaning for decades and
they've been putting out
films that you know propagandize
um
in their Direction and they've been
doing that for decades but they used to
be able to do it in a way that people
found found interesting and found
entertaining and wanted to go watch the
movies
they're not as able to do that anymore
part of that is like we always talk
about it's the kind of Christian film
phenomenon where they do the same thing
in the reverse with Christian films do
they put them they put the message up
before anything so they go message first
they worry about getting the message
across before they worry about actually
putting out an entertaining piece of
content
that's part of it I think also
you know
they don't think that the masses are
worthy of being appealed to in the first
place I think
they think almost like they would be
it'd be beneath them
to try to appeal to the masses
because they have contempt for that they
have too much contempt for the masses at
this point
to actually try to connect with them I
think that's part of the issue and
that'll do it for this portion of the
show is move over to the members block
hope to see you there if not talk to you
tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]